[Música]
el desarrollo de la situación entre
rusia y ucrania se agudizó luego de que
el presidente vladimir putin reconociera
independencia de las autoproclamadas
repúblicas separatistas de donges que en
lugares en la región del donbass al este
de ucrania el mandatario ruso ordenó el
envío de tropas para según el mantener
la paz en esos territorios desde 2014
estas regiones están controladas por
grupos pro rusos la decisión de moscú va
grave entonces la crisis que se teme
pueda desencadenar en un conflicto de
grandes dimensiones occidente está
preocupado de que el reconocimiento de
la independencia en ese lugar sirva de
pretexto a rusia para invadir ambos
territorios con la excusa de defender a
la población ruso parlante y todo esto
lo vamos a analizar con jesús manuel
pérez triana analista de seguridad y
defensa jesús gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
le pregunto qué se puede esperar
entonces en este conflicto una acción
militar rusa en ucrania es realmente
posible
bueno yo creo que el reconocimiento
diplomático de estas dos repúblicas lo
que va a permitir es buscar una
justificación legal al despliegue de
tropas rusas pero dentro del territorio
que ya estaba fuera del control del
gobierno de kiev y yo creo que esto en
el fondo nos aleja de la posibilidad de
un conflicto armado porque rusia al
menos ahora tiene una ganancia es decir
ha ganado algo de lo útil le pueden
enseñar a la opinión pública rusa pues
que de esta crisis ha sacado algo en
claro y es
y consolidar el control sobre esas dos
repúblicas que en el fondo siempre
habían sido menos teledirigidas desde
moscú pero que ahora ya todo se hace
abierto y a la luz del día entonces está
violando la soberanía realmente de
ucrania con esto rusia dice que no la
comunidad internacional dice que si el
presidente dice lenski dice que si
realmente si se estaba violando la
soberanía ucraniana bueno pues lo que es
lo que ha sucedido es que el vladimir
putin y su gobierno ha reconocido
diplomáticamente como si fuesen países
soberanos e independientes en dos
territorios que toda la comunidad
internacional considera a parte de
ucrania entonces esto es una cuestión de
como aceptamos de legítima es a ese
reconocimiento
los rusos de irán por ejemplo que algo
así fue lo que sucedió en el año 91
cuando alemania por ejemplo reconocido
eslovenia croacia y que ellos
simplemente están haciendo exactamente
lo mismo a rusia le gusta mucho por así
decirlo
utilizar antecedentes de cosas que ha
dicho accidente y decir bueno ellos son
igual de inocentes a la hora de llevar
acciones evidentemente esto en tierra
por completo los acuerdos de paz de mis
hace que la situación sea más complicada
y desde luego que no es un un avance
hacia la paz y la concordia lo que ha
hecho rusia cuáles son entonces las
opciones en la mesa que tendría la
comunidad internacional para tratar de
salirse de este conflicto de la vía por
la vía diplomática como todos quieren
bueno para empezar la solución militar
está totalmente descartada ya que ahora
hay un acuerdo bilateral entre estas dos
repúblicas separatistas rusia se
acogería la carta de que ellos tienen un
tratado que les obliga a usar a proteger
y salvaguardar estas repúblicas entonces
que ucrania utilice la fuerza queda
totalmente descartado entonces lo que
nos queda todo
de medidas dentro de lo que son pues
sanciones y medidas políticas y lo hemos
visto ya el gobierno alemán ha anunciado
que va a cancelar el gran proyecto de
gasoducto que él llevaba gas
directamente desde rusia por el mar
báltico de los 32
estamos viendo que se van a preparar
toda una serie de sanciones muy
específicas contra personajes
del gobierno ruso decir que más que
hagan intentar que afecten a la
población civil rusa normal del
ciudadano ruso de pie
sanciones que sean muy específicas y
estaba hablando de hacer una lista de
personalidades rusas entonces lo que
pasa que claro entre con que rusia haya
al final haya hecho efectivo el control
de un territorio y una serie de
sanciones económicas que
darán resultados y se impactaran en la
vida rusa pues a largo plazo pues los
rusos ahora mismo tienen la sensación de
que han salido pues a sacar ha salido
ganando pero porque en este momento
jesús porque en este momento de tensión
máxima digamos entre rusia occidente de
ucrania él toma esta decisión porque no
lo hizo antes digamos que volteando un
poco la tortilla y viendo lo del lado de
otra posibilidad putin no hace esto para
presionar más a la comunidad
internacional y realmente buscar
soluciones realmente sentarse en una
mesa de diálogo luego que no tuvo
respuestas satisfactorias digamos de
eeuu a sus propuestas de seguridad no
sería también es a lo mejor una
intención de vladimir putin de hacerlo
en este momento generar más presión y
realmente tomar cartas en el asunto de
van dibujando en la mesa de diálogo
bueno es una gran pregunta porque rusia
hizo esto después de ocho años de crisis
y ucrania la sensación es que hay la
ventana de oportunidad que rusia tenía
de influir en la vida política y educar
ya se iba cerrando la sociedad ucraniana
se ha ido haciendo más pro occidental
las fuerzas armadas ucranianas se han
ido
modernizando hay acuerdos bilaterales
con turquía para la fabricación de
drones con reino unido para la mejora de
su armada y la sensación es que esa
ucrania más moderna más avanzada con
unas fuerzas armadas mejor podría en
algún momento
romper el alto el fuego o el falso alto
el fuego en vigor desde desde el acuerdo
de mick y algún día retomar por la
fuerza las dos pequeñas repúblicas que
en el que habían caído por así decirlo
en la prioridad de la política rusa
entonces para rusia se cerraba una
ventana de oportunidad de influir en los
asuntos ucraniano de todas formas viendo
el discurso de anoche de putin viendo
como rusia encaja esto en el orden
internacional europeo lo que estamos
viendo es que lo que rusia tiene una
mentalidad revanchista que no es que
quieren darle marcha atrás al reloj y
renegociar con eeuu y con europa el
orden que surgió después del fin de la
de la guerra fría por así decirlo rusia
nunca había hecho esto porque se sentía
débil porque es un país que a los años
90 por ejemplo estuvo muy dividido y muy
debilitado internamente y ahora con un
presidente como yo iba a ir en que es
transmitir una imagen de debilidad con
la retirada de las tropas de afganistán
con una rusia más asertiva con un eeuu
desafiado por china pues ahora rusia ve
la oportunidad de poner encima de la
mesa que se renegocie el orden
internacional en europa es lo que le
quería preguntar precisamente entonces
putin gea tratando de dibujar nuevamente
el mapa político antes de la caída de la
unión soviética eso también no
implicaría que más adelante ya que era
el control total de ucrania por así
decirlo
claro es que lo que hemos visto que en
el 2 en la crisis del 2014 rusia se
quedó con crimea en la crisis del 2022 y
establece un control de estas
establece un motor porque hace un
acuerdo de asociación de paz y un
reconocimiento diplomático pro esto
simplemente significa que hacen ya
visible y notorio el control sobre estas
dos repúblicas separatistas entonces la
pregunta es en la próxima crisis porque
esto simplemente
es cerrar
pues
evidentemente viendo las listas de lo
que putin ha demandado efectivamente
esto no tiene que ver con ucrania tiene
que ver con todo el resto de países
cercanos y
cercanos porque fueron miembros de la
unión soviética y que están
de la otan europea y rusia no es que
tanto quiera anexionarse los y
controlarlos sino que quiere neutralizar
los quiere que allí no haya despliegue
de las fuerzas de la otan quiere que en
esos países no haya en su política
exterior y sus y sus fuerzas armadas
estén vinculadas con occidente por cien
cielo quiere crear un colchón
sanitario pero si decirlo de seguridad
de países neutralizados lo que se llama
a finalización la situación de finlandia
la guerra fría un país neutral con unas
fuerzas armadas limitadas y sin alianzas
militares con occidente